hmm I don't know deploying the same app
to app engine Cloud functions and Cloud
run with no code changes I'm skeptical
no it's true I can do it I'll show you
okay this had better be good
[Music]
welcome to this extended episode of
serverless expeditions we're going to
pick up from right where our previous
video left off helping you pick the
right serverless platform we're back
with our friend Wes who introduced that
sample app and ran it locally I'm going
to keep him Honest by making him show
that he can really deployed to all three
platforms today
are you ready Wes Thanks Martin just
what I wanted to do a Live recorded demo
in front of thousands of Developers
no pressure Wes the main idea is to show
folks out there that if you create the
right scaffolding around your app you
can shift your app from one platform to
another that's right Martin when doing
your due diligence exploring app engine
Cloud functions and Cloud run you're
going to pick the right one for your
needs and if those needs change our
platforms are similar and flexible
enough so you can switch if need be in
other words you can't really make a
mistake here
all right I can't wait can we get
started yep I've got a node.js and
python versions of this app we'll start
with the node deployments first there's
a little bit of drama with python but
we'll do those afterwards of course if
you're not interested in node you can
skip ahead to the python part of the
show right now in either case the code
is in the same repo we'll link to all of
the resources afterwards so let's just
look at those deployments now
to get started make your way to the repo
all of the nebulous serverless sample
apps are here but we're only interested
in Cloud today so click into the cloud
folder then choose your Dev environment
say node.js
you can scroll down get familiar with
the files and get a preview of the
different deployments but we're not set
up yet so go back up and click on a code
lab there's one Consolidated code lab
for node but all of the Python ones are
split up so pick the one for the
deployments you're interested in we're
not doing any codelab word for word but
we are going to follow the setup
instructions this first part is just an
overview and an optional survey moving
on part two is where the real work
begins you need to go to the cloud
console and create a new project or
reuse an existing one if you're new to
gcp every app is associated with a
project which is a logical container for
all the cloud resources used by your app
mine's already set up as you can see
here so pause now to get yourself set up
and enable billing we'll talk about
costs in a minute moving on part three
is about enabling Services the sample
app demos how to use the cloud
translation API so we have to enable
that
we're going to deploy to app engine
Cloud functions and Cloud run so those
need to be enabled as well along with
the artifact registry for registering
Cloud run container images
there are two ways of enabling all five
the first is on the command line with
the gcloud command and the other is in
the cloud console as a developer I'm not
patient enough to dig around the cloud
console to enable things so I'm just
going to copy the one line command
I'm not always on a computer with the
cloud SDK installed so I'm going to do
this in the cloud shell which is in
lockdown mini VM tied to my project
available from any browser
from anywhere in the cloud console click
on the cloud shell icon at the top right
it brings up a Linux shell with many
common Dev tools pre-installed
let's paste that command to activate all
of our services and boom it works
before going to the code a word on costs
all the services app engine Cloud
functions and Cloud run have a free tier
as does the cloud translation API
so running the app shouldn't incur any
costs
but there are build and storage costs
minor but they're there so check to see
if you have a free cloud storage tier in
your region afterwards and delete those
build files or shut down your entire
project to be safe
the final setup is in step four to get
the code go back to the repo and get the
zip file or just run git clone like
we're doing now
we're not running locally so we can skip
checking the local Dev environment in
step 5. if you want to review the code
in Step 6 go for it but it's not
necessary this video is all about
deploying so we're skipping this part
too
the rest of the video assumes that we're
always starting from this point where
you've got a project enable billing
enabled all the services that we're
going to use and you have all the code
ready to go
are you ready to start deploying all
right let's go
okay deploy the node sample app to app
engine is there any special config setup
for this deployment as you can see from
the Ruby nope is ready to go as is the
command to deploy to app engine is
gcloud app deploy so just run it like
the other deployments it should take
under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
app engine is regional so you'll be
prompted for the region on your first
deploy but it's the only time you'll be
asked mine has already been set to us
Central and that's why you didn't see it
the only thing unique to app engine here
is the app.yaml config file where you
specify the runtime and you only need to
choose a supported runtime say note 16.
now that it's deployed hit up the target
URL and make a translation congrats the
node app is successfully deployed to app
engine
okay deploy the node sample app to Cloud
functions is there any special config
set up for this deployment as you can
see from the readme nope it's ready to
go as is
the command to deploy to Cloud functions
is gcloud functions deploy paste the
entire command you see in the repos
readme or in the code lab like the other
deployments it should take under a
minute let's discuss a few things about
this deployment while we're waiting
because there's no config file like app
engine the command line is a little
longer you have to specify a function
name say translate a supported runtime
say note 16 the entry point the trigger
type and a flag allowing for
unauthenticated traffic for this demo a
cloud function is regional so you'll be
prompted for the region on your first
deploy but it's the only time you'll be
asked mine has already been set to us
Central 1 and that's why you didn't see
that
now that it's deployed hit the HTTP
trigger URL and make a translation
congrats the node app is successfully
deployed to Cloud functions
okay deploy the node sample app to Cloud
run
is there any special config setup for
this deployment as you can see from the
Ruby nope it's ready to go as is
the command to deploy to Cloud run is
gcloud run deploy paste the entire
command you see in the readme or in the
code lab
like the other deployments it should
take under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
because there's no config file like app
engine the command line is a little
longer you have to specify a service
name say translate a flag along for
unauthenticated traffic for this demo a
flag specifying we're deploying from
source code instead of an already built
container image and that we want fully
managed Cloud run
you'll be prompted for a region to
deploy the service to if it's not on the
command line so that's why I put us West
2 on my command line so it's completely
non-interactive
now that it's deployed hit the service
URL and make a translation congrats the
node app is successfully deployed to
Cloud run
OK deploy the sample app to python 2 app
engine is there any special config set
up for this deployment yep from the
readme you can see there's only one
extra step run the PIP install command
to copy or vendor or self-bundle the
required third-party libraries to the
lib folder paste the entire command from
the readme or code lab once that's done
we're good to go the command to deploy
to app engine is gcloud app deploy so
just run it like the other deployments
it should take under a minute let's
discuss a few things about this
deployment while we're waiting app
engine is regional so you'll be prompted
for the region on your first deploy but
it's the only time you'll be asked mine
has already been set to us Central and
that's why you didn't see it now that
it's deployed hit the target URL and
make a translation congrats the python 2
app is successfully deployed to app
engine
okay deploy the sample app to Python 3
app engine
is there any special config set up for
this deployment yep you can see from the
readme there's only one extra step edit
the app.yaml file to switch from python
2 to 3 by enabling the Python 3 runtime
and deleting all the other lines once
you save you're good to go
the command to deploy to app engine is
gcloud app deploy so just run it
like the other deployments it should
take under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
apogen is regional so you'll be prompted
for the region on your first deploy but
it's the only time you'll be asked mine
has already been set to us Central and
that's why you didn't see it
the app.yaml file is unique to app
engine and no other serverless platforms
now that it's deployed hit the target
URL and make a translation congrats the
Python 3 app is successfully deployed to
app engine
okay deploy the Python 3 sample app to
Cloud functions is there any special
config set up for this deployment not
really but the readme has an optional
step
you can delete the app.yaml and app
engine config.py files and the lib
folder if you have one none of these are
used by Cloud functions
the command to deploy to Cloud functions
is gcloud functions deploy paste the
entire command you see from the readme
or the code lab
like the other deployments it should
take under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
because there's no config file like app
engine the command line is a little
longer you must specify the function
name we'll call it translate a supported
runtime say python 310 a trigger type
and a flag allowing for unauthenticated
traffic for this demo
a cloud function is regional so you'll
be prompted for the region on your first
deploy but it's the only time you'll be
asked mine has already been set to us
Central one and that's why you didn't
see it
now that it's deployed hit the HTTP
trigger URL and make a translation
congrats the Python 3 app is
successfully deployed to Cloud functions
okay deploy the python 2 sample app to
Cloud run with Docker is there any
special config set up for this
deployment you can delete the app.yaml
and app engine config.py files and the
lib folder if you have one none are used
by Cloud run
the command to deploy to Cloud run is
gcloud run deploy paste the entire
command from the readme or code lab like
the other deployments it should take
under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting now because there's no config
file like app engine the command line
was a little longer you have to specify
a service name say translate a flag
allowing for unauthenticated traffic for
this demo a flag specifying we're
deploying from source code instead of an
already built container image and that
we want fully managed Cloud run
you'll be prompted for a region to
deploy the service to if it's not on the
command line so I put us West 2 on my
command so it's completely
non-interactive
now that it's deployed hit the service
URL and make a translation
congrats the python 2 app is
successfully deployed to Cloud run with
docker
OK deploy the Python 3 sample app to
Cloud run with Docker is there any
special config setup for this deployment
yep from the readme you can see there's
only two extra steps the first of which
is optional you can delete the app.yaml
and app engine config.py files and the
lib folder if you have one none are used
by Cloud run
the most critical change is to edit the
docker file replacing the python 2 base
image with a one for python 3. once
that's done you're ready to go
the command to deploy to Cloud run is
gcloud run deploy
paste the entire command you see in the
readme or the code lab
like the other deployments it should
take under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
because there's no config file like app
engine the command line is a little
longer you have to specify a service
name say translate a flag allowing for
unauthenticated traffic for this demo a
flag specifying we're deploying from
source code instead of an already built
container image and that we want fully
managed Cloud run
you'll be prompted for a region to
deploy as the service to if it's not on
the command line so I put us West 2 on
my command line so it's completely
non-interactive
now that it's deployed hit the service
URL and make a translation
congrats the Python 3 app is
successfully deployed to Cloud run with
docker
okay deploy the Python 3 sample app to
cloudron with Cloud build packs is there
any special config setup for this
deployment yep from the readme you can
see there's only two extra steps the
first of which is optional you can
delete the app.yaml and app engine
config.py files and the loop folder if
you have one none are used by Cloud run
the most critical change is to delete
the docker file once you're done you're
ready to go
the command to deploy to Cloud run is
gcloud run deploy paste the entire
command from the readme or codelab like
the other deployments it should take
under a minute let's discuss a few
things about this deployment while we're
waiting
now why did we delete that Docker file
that's the beauty of build packs you
don't need a Docker file or need to know
anything about containers or docker the
build pack system introspects your app
and dynamically builds a virtual Docker
file for you this means those unfamiliar
with Docker or containers can also use
cloud run
because there's no config file like app
engine the command line was a little
longer you have to specify a service
name say translate a flag allowing for
unauthenticated traffic for this demo a
flag specifying we're deploying from
source code instead of an already built
container image and that we want fully
managed Cloud run you'll be prompted for
a region to deploy your service to if
it's not on the command line so that's
why I put Usos 2 on my command line so
it's completely non-interactive
now that it's deployed hit the service
URL and make a translation congrats the
Python 3 app is successfully deployed to
Cloud run with cloud buildpex wow I
didn't believe you at first but you
actually did it Wes well I'm not shocked
that you can deploy this app to all
three platforms I was surprised that you
can do it with no code changes neat
right well admittedly there's a tiny bit
of cheating due to some Cloud functions
if Dev code and you wouldn't code like
that from the ground up but it does
provide that flexibility sounds good now
everyone's probably wondering how they
can try these deployments are there any
guides
definitely go to the repo not only will
you find the code but you'll also find
links to all of the code Labs guiding
you through all of these deployments the
one for node is all in one but the
python ones are broken out separately
due to the extra tweaking that must be
done to configuration out of the box
thanks for that pointer now everyone can
deploy this app to whatever serverless
platform they want are there any next
steps Wes
yes the app we shared uses a cloud API
the repo also has other samples that
show you how to call non-cloud Google
apis from serverless for example there's
an app using the Google Sheets API and
another one using the Google Maps
geocoding API hopefully we'll add more
in the future and maybe you and I can
film another video covering these soon
and looking forward to that Wes if you
the viewer have any questions for us
about what we covered here please let us
know in the comments below
also let us know what you'd like to see
in future episodes till then Happy
serverless Journeys
[Music]